- So wait in the book you revealed
that you and your wife both have
a connection to Rob Lowe.
And I know that connection,
but everyone else doesn't, so explain.
- You know, when you get
together with another actor,
and this is true, and
this is my whole life,
when you start dating someone,
one of the things you do, you have
an awareness of like, by the way,
I was in a play with this person, or
you figure out who you've both kissed.
- This is a conversation?
- Yeah. It's a thing.
(crowd laughs)
I mean it's true of any new relationship.
- Not me. I don't wanna know any past.
(crowd laughs)
- But eventually you learn about
each other significant others.
And in this case, because
he's a marquee name,
it came up at some point that Megan
in the movie about last night had
this crazy throat kissing
scene with Rob Lowe,
where she plays this floozy, trying
to distract him from Demi Moore.
And they have this crazy
French kissing scene.
And at some point I randomly saw it.
We were at a hotel and
it happened to be on TV.
And it was so traumatic where I was like.
(crowd laughing)
- (laughs) What are you doing?
- It was 15 years later,
but I said, "Honey,
"you clearly are in love with Rob Lowe."
(crowd laughs)
(Kelly laughs)
This is gonna be a situation between us.
And so it always kind of stuck with me,
but then until some years later on
Parks and Recreation, in an episode where
I think Rob Lowe's character finds out
that it's Ron Swanson's birthday and he
ends up kissing me on the
mouth in this episode.
(crowd laughs)
- Both been there.
- At which point I was like,
"Okay, honey, I get it."
(crowd laughs)
(Kelly laughs)
Everything's cool.
- It's even! (laughs)
- Everything's fine. If you stepped
back a little ways, and squint,
you could say that we've had a threesome.
(Kelly laughs dramatically)
- That's how it is in Hollywood.
- That's what your book
should have been called.
(everyone laughs)
- Our Threesome with Rob Lowe.
That's amazing!